bonsoir et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors comment
accueillez-vous ce rapport de luigi je
dirais qu'ils confirment ce que dix ans
et que beaucoup disent aujourd'hui que
ce soit sur le continent latino
américain mais y compris chez les
progressistes de par le monde sait que
la cabale politique et le procès
politique qui est fait contre evo
morales suite au coup d'état qui a été
perpétré appel quelque part
institutionnels après les élections
présidentielles de dire que le mur
s'effondre de cette persécution evo
morales on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui et
je dirais que le rapport qui a été remis
par human rights watch montre bien
commun quelque part les accusations ne
sont pas motivés et alors que le
processus électoral est entravée je
dirais de façon à ce que evo morales ne
puisse pas être candidat je rappellerai
parce qu'il faut resituer quand même le
contexte je rappellerai qu'il ya eu
l'élection présidentielle ou evo morales
a été élu tout de suite l'opposition a
protesté et organisé je dirais des
mouvements violents afin de demander la
démission ce soi-disant des
irrégularités je dis bien des
irrégularités 18 parlait même pas de
fraude et pour pas que le pays soit à
feuilla ça je dirais qu evo morales a eu
à ce moment là la responsabilité de dire
en refaire je démissionnais à carreaux
faire les élections
il a reposé sur le champ démocratique et
c'est à partir de là qu'on a vu qu'on
parle la persécution a commencé d'abord
ce rêve aux morales après sur beaucoup
de ses collaborateurs et de ses
camarades du mas et en même temps sur
les fonctionnaires et donc c'est depuis
des décennies kallisté autres et je
crois que aujourd'hui le rapport il
montera alors que les élections
approchent qui a été repoussée plusieurs
fois d'ailleurs il faut le rappeler du
fait seul delà du gouvernement en place
aujourd'hui on boit en commun
il ya la peur quelque part que le mas
reviennent au pouvoir parce qu'en même
temps il faut il ya une réalité est
celle là ne trompe pas malgré tout ce
qui a pu être fait cette cabale
politique qui est monté contre le masque
pro morales
le candidat décidée par le mas puisque
il a été décrété que morales ne pouvait
pas être candidat à la présidentielle
luis arce et arrive largement en tête
des sondages
et c'est au moment aussi où evo morales
est proposé pour être candidat aux
sénatoriales à cochabamba la province où
il est natif et 2008 où on vient de
décréter aujourd'hui encore qu' il ne
peut être candidat non plus à la
sénatoriale
je dirais que ce rapport il amène des
preuves en même temps deux de ces
persécutions de ces deux de preuves
d'accusation qui paraissent motivée par
des intérêts politiques de la part de
ceux qui ont fait le coup d'état
institutionnel et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui ça demande beaucoup plus
de mobilisation pour que la démocratie
revienne en fait un beau libye et que
les que ce soit le peuple qui trinque et
alors qu'elle influence selon vous ce
rapport peut-il avoir sur le traitement
d'evo morales par le gouvernement
provisoire libyen
je pense que le pouvoir en place
aujourd'hui ne va pas remettre à neuf à
remettre en cause ce rapport parce
qu'ici il ya eu plusieurs démarches y
compris jusqu'au tribunal international
où ils ont essayé de d'accuser vos mots
à l'aise terrorisme et autres
je pense bien même temps il ya
aujourd'hui un mouvement qui est très
fort en bolivie y compris des
progressistes y compris qui gêne aux
entournures quelque part le pouvoir en
place et le gouvernement et donc qu'il
est possible qu'à un moment donné les
rapports de force s'inversent aussi et
que la voie du dialogue et reviennent
mais en même temps je pense qu'il ya à
l'échelle internationale il ya besoin
que les gouvernements de pays qui se
disent démocratiques la france je dirais
l'europe intervienne aujourd'hui de
manière forte pour que les halls et les
élections puissent s'organiser
les bonnes conditions et en même temps
je crois que la question des baux
morales et y compris de tous ceux qui
sont accusés comme lui de tous les noms
il faut que aujourd'hui ses chansons
revues que le gouvernement cesse
aujourd'hui la persécution politique d
un crime qui peut s'en venait mais je
dirai pas ce que je disais il ya le
contexte aussi latino américains qu'il
faut regarder
la ficelle est un peu grosse quand on
accuse evo morales et donc d'un
terrorisme de génocide parce que je
passe les non officiels
elle apparaît un peu gros comme un nez
de clown jamie de diers fois deux
visages aston et d'un gigantesque salle
et latino américains et la recette est
le processus qui a engagé en bolivie on
voit que ce sont les mêmes qui ont été
engagées au brésil contre lula contre
dilma rousseff c'est également et coup
d'état institutionnel au venezuela où y
compris juan garrido de l'opposition est
en difficulté par rapport aux élections
qu'ils ont proposé ces législatives ce à
propos de son propre camp
c'est en équateur là mais les mêmes
mesures contre les reflets et colère je
pense qu'il ya des similitudes qui ne
trompe pas aujourd'hui il ya washington
je dirais et l'étonnant quelques pas du
néolibéralisme qui peut peuvent accepter
aujourd'hui alors qu'il pensait qu'ils
avaient eu leur revanche par rapport aux
gouvernements progressistes négative qui
mesure qu aujourd'hui la chose n'est pas
faite et que les peuples européenne les
choses à mai et je dirais que le peuple
bolivien est en train aussi de la
remettre à demain de la reprendre en
main et je pense que le rapport humain
droit et chaud à haut risque à avoir
donc apparaître en même temps qu'ils se
rendent sur les mêmes mêmes conclusions
de cette persécution politique quels
risques en cours aujourd'hui vos morales
avec la ley les poursuites engagées
contre lui c'est grave quand on voit les
poursuites on poursuit de terrorisme
comme poursuivre de génocide
je veux dire on peut craindre le risque
y compris par rapport à evo morales est
compris d'autres aujourd'hui compris
qu'ils sont poursuivis
17 à l'heure y compris pour certains qui
sont emprisonnés et donc le risque et
les grains c'est pour ça que je veux
dire est que la communauté
internationale ne peut pas à rester à
regarder le film
il faut un moment donné qu'elle
intervienne avec tous les leviers qui
sont les siens je dirais levier qui est
important c'est effectivement aussi
l'organisation nationale des de l'onu
qui peut qui pourrait intervenir et
notamment avec une france qui fait
partie de l'est des pays qui participent
de manière permanente au conseil de
sécurité
je dirais même temps il ya des
institutions qui sont fortes comme comme
la communauté européenne et autres qui
doivent abandonner travailler dans le
sens que je sais ce que c'est ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui de manière grave a
molli vie et confie qu'il cesse comme je
le disais dans d'autres pays comme c'est
le cas en equateur aujourd'hui au
venezuela
aujourd'hui la porte est ouverte par le
gouvernement et par maduro pour
retrouver la voie du dialogue avoir
démocratique par des législatives et
présidentielle y compris avec appel à
skis et les observateurs internationaux
qui viennent comme ça se fait dans
d'autres pays c'est à dire pour donner
les garanties à même temps du scrutin ou
et compris niveau-là ce bureau a libéré
aujourd'hui beaucoup de prisonniers
politiques quasi gagman tous les
prisonniers dits politiques qui étaient
incarcérés
il était une des bases quelque part pour
reprendre le dialogue et on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui trois gaido ne prend pas
cette voie comme aujourd'hui la
présidente qui s'est autoproclamé en
bolivie du pcf en charge des relations
avec l amérique latine